digamos que estamos teniendo una fiesta
de cumpleaños y estos son los niños en
la fiesta de cumpleaños todos los niños
tienen edades diferentes y lo que
queremos saber es cuántos niños de la
misma edad tenemos para ayudarnos a
pensar en eso podemos dibujar lo que es
conocido como gráfica de líneas y
siempre he visto el término
sí
d
me miras
un poco confuso porque en mi cerebro
utilizas mucho más los puntos que las
líneas pero veamos lo que es una gráfica
de líneas lo que haré es
dibujaré creo que esto involucra una
línea justo aquí dibujar una línea aquí
abajo y luego crearé un rubro para cada
una de las edades
veamos tenemos estudiantes aquí desde la
edad de tres años hasta los siete años
puedo decir
años
cuatro años cinco años seis años y siete
años no tengo que ir a los dos oa los
ocho años porque no hay niños en esas
edades aunque podría si quisiera y luego
veo cuántos niños tengo de cada edad
bueno tengo una persona asistiendo a la
fiesta
viana ella tiene tres años así que
pondré podría poner una equis aquí o un
punto
gráficas de líneas diferentes pondrá en
algo diferente aquí pero eso me muestra
que tengo esta está fiestera de tres
años aquí ahora tengo a iván de cinco
años hay alguien acá hay alguien que
estaría aquí que tiene cinco años puedes
pensar en este punto este representa a
iván que tiene cinco años luego tienes a
silvia que también tiene cinco años ella
también tiene cinco años eso significa
que tenemos una segunda persona en la
fiesta que tiene cinco años por lo que
en cinco años ahora tenemos dos personas
este es iván y ésta es silvia luego
tienes a jose que tiene seis hay una
persona de seis años luego también
tienes a víctor que tiene seis años
déjame hacerlo en el mismo color también
tenemos a víctor que tiene seis años
pongamos los en el rubro de 6 años luego
tenemos a louis que tiene 7 louis que
tiene 7 ese sería un punto ahí y luego
finalmente tenemos a ana que también
tiene 6 años que también tiene 6 años
solo con eso puede tomar todos los datos
que tenía en esta tabla y pude ponerlos
en esta gráfica de líneas y la razón por
la cual esta gráfica de líneas es útil
es que nos permite ver cuántos niños de
cada edad tenemos podría ser un poco más
confuso solo ver la tabla aquí porque si
vemos la gráfica de líneas es muy claro
que no hay nadie aquí que tenga cuatro
años
mira la mayoría de la gente tiene seis
años y si nos preguntamos a nosotros
mismos
cuántos sin ni siquiera tuvieras esto es
más déjame solo quitarlo
si ni siquiera tuviéramos eso allí si no
tuviéramos la tabla y sólo tuviéramos la
gráfica de líneas y si alguien quisiera
mira estas son las edades justo aquí
estás son
3 en años cumplidos y cada punto
representa un estudiante que está en la
fiesta basándonos en esta gráfica de
líneas cuánta gente tiene más de cinco
años podrías ver esto y decir más de
cinco años
eso sería seis años o siete años no
estamos seguros de que hubiera alguien
de 10 o 11 y así sucesivamente así que
veamos todos los puntos veamos a todos
los puntos aquí que tienen más de 5 años
hay tres de seis años y hay una de siete
años así que hay uno dos tres cuatro
personas mayores a cinco años podrías
hacerlo al revés podrías decir cuántas
personas tienen menos de cinco años y
luego podrías decir bien menor de cinco
años serían
años o cuatro años y cuando ves a esos
puntos
ves que sólo hay un punto sólo uno de
los asistentes es menor de cinco años
espero que hayas encontrado eso
interesante